well one thing I often hear from people
is I want to do this side hustle
therefore I'm going to quit my job and
I'm going to make it happen I don't feel
like hang on hang on like don't don't
quit your job until you've at least done
it for a little while yep in in the
weekends and years weekends evenings
um but I guess these days it's it's sort
of become a bit unfashionable to talk
about doing the stuff on the weekends
and evenings and things and everyone's
like oh but like sustainability and like
you know work-life balance and mental
health and all that kind of stuff
rightly so the people who sort of
succeed are the ones who do add in that
extra level of hustle extra level of
grind if you want to use those words to
make something work there's gonna have
to be a period of time when you have to
go outside your comfort zone you're
going to have to work harder than you
you probably helpfully should over a
long period of time but you're not doing
that forever so that was one year when I
worked crazy crazy amount of hours I was
doing a full-time job with a three-hour
drive backwards and forwards to home an
hour and a half each way yeah and then
working in the evening so there was
crazy hours for a year big deal